[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes del
programa semanal de France 24 sobre el
Éxodo nos saluda Juliette riaño
[Música]
los sirios son perseguidos en Líbano
desde 2019 el consejo superior de
defensa ordenó la deportación De
refugiados sirios que ingresaran al país
a través de pasos irregulares esa Norma
desencadenó una serie de violaciones a
los derechos humanos de quienes buscaron
protección en Líbano en los últimos
meses las autoridades libanesas
endurecieron las medidas de control
hacia los sirios con campañas de arresto
y devoluciones irregulares nuestro
equipo en beirut de Diego Ibarra Sánchez
con el informe
camina entre los restos de su campamento
desmantelado por el ejército libanés
hace unas semanas huyó con su familia de
la guerra de Siria y se instalaron hace
más de una década en el Líbano pero ya
no se sienten seguros en este país que
los acogió no nos quieren aquí pero
tampoco podemos volver a Siria Porque
muchos estamos buscados por haber
escapado del servicio militar Mira cómo
vivimos nuestros hijos duermen a la
intemperie hace unos meses que las
autoridades libanesas imponen medidas
severas para regular a una población de
dos millones de refugiados sirios la
mayor concentración per cápita del mundo
Javi ya llegó al Líbano de forma ilegal
y podría ser arrestada y deportada
los militares entraron y nos sacaron a
todos de las tiendas se llevaron a mi
sobrino y no he vuelto a saber de él
tengo miedo organizaciones humanitarias
alertan sobre el destino de cientos de
refugiados que han sido devueltos a
Siria y corren el riesgo de tortura
enjuiciamiento mientras que las calles
del Líbano azota por la crisis los
libaneses se encuentran los migrantes
una escapatoria sus problemas
nos han llenado el país de campos de
refugiados las mujeres sirias no paran
de engendrar hijos para así recibir más
ayudas
amale refugiada irregular y lleva días
sin salir de casa con las redadas teme
que se la lleven a ella y a sus hijos la
vitalidad de las detenciones ha llevado
los refugiados a reducir sus movimientos
por temor a ser devueltos
no nos queda nada allí mi marido murió
en nuestra casa fue destruida aquí en el
Líbano he podido cuidar de mis hijos no
podemos volver
el riesgo de las devoluciones forzosas
se agrava a medida que los Países Árabes
están normalizando sus relaciones con
Siria sin vistas a una solución a la
guerra que garantice el retorno seguro
miles de refugiados sirios se enfrentan
a un futuro incierto aquí en el Líbano
entre la deportación y el temor a
regresar ante las recientes denuncias
sobre las graves violaciones a las que
son sometidos los sirios en Líbano los
organismos de ayuda levantan la mano
para pedir acciones los refugiados viven
en medio del miedo a ser arrestados a
sufrir torturas Y ser nuevamente
Víctimas de persecución pero ahora en el
país que los acogió hablamos con Carlos
de las Heras responsable de temas de
oriente medio en amnistía internacional
sobre el Por qué se debe de tener las
devoluciones de sirios a su país Tenemos
que tener en cuenta que los últimos
meses las autoridades libanesas han
deportado a decenas de personas
refugiadas a Siria son personas que
habían entrado en el país en algunos
casos de forma irregular o que o cuyas
tarjetas de residencia Pues habían
caducado no estas expulsiones han venido
acompañadas de un alarmante
argumento o aumento del argumento y de
La retórica contra las personas
refugiadas y de otras medidas bastante
coercitivas
el Por qué básicamente porque las
autoridades libanesas han gestionado mal
una crisis económica del país de una
forma deliberada y esto empobrecido a
millones de personas y las han privado
de derechos básicos sin embargo en lugar
de poner en marcha las medidas y las
reformas necesarias pues han recurrido a
emplear personas refugiadas como el
chivo expiatorio de sus propios fracasos
es decir son quienes están pagando por
así decir las responsabilidades de otras
personas No hay nada que justifique el
hecho de arrancar Pues de su cama de sus
viviendas a cientos de personas sirias a
hombres mujeres a niños y a niñas a
altas horas de la madrugada para por
ejemplo entregarlas a un gobierno el
sirio del que huyeron buscando
protección
el riesgo de las deportaciones
irregulares de refugiados sirios es
altísimo a que se enfrentan los sirios
que son devueltos a un país del que
salieron en busca de protección así lo
documentan amnistía internacional
si aquí es muy importante
destacar que Siria no es un país seguro
no es un país seguro para que regresen
las personas refugiadas que tuvieron o
han tenido que dejar el país Aquí tanto
organizaciones locales como
internacionales
continúan a día de hoy documentando
violaciones de Derechos Humanos A manos
de las fuerzas armadas de las fuerzas de
seguridad de los militares sirios contra
no solo la población que está en Siria
sino también contra personas sirias que
han retornado que han que se han visto
obligadas a volver a Siria el caso o a
varios ejemplos de estos de estos de
este trato pues podemos hablar de
detenciones ilegítimas de detenciones
arbitrarias de tortura y otros malos
tratos de incluso violencia sexual o
mucho más allá de desapariciones
forzadas y ejecuciones extrajudiciales
Es cierto que las hostilidades militares
en Siria en los últimos meses han y que
sin embargo la propensión del gobierno
de Siria a cometer violaciones de
Derechos Humanos no ha remitido y no ha
disminuido como las hostilidades como te
decía la tortura las desapariciones
forzadas o las detenciones arbitrarias
que obligaron a muchas de estas personas
sirias que han buscado refugio en otros
países como el Líbano soy
desafortunadamente hoy día siguen siendo
también habituales en este país con las
deportaciones estaría violando el
principio de no devolución una norma
vinculante del derecho internacional que
prohíbe a los estados de volver a las
personas a un lugar donde corren peligro
hasta que inmigrantes de France 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrante f-24
sigan con más información en France 24 y
24.com
[Música]